nice defense from Mitchell Robinson
Morris walks him in a three that's good
dr. Suarez two for two from downtown
Dotson back out Dennis Smith still
plenty of time shot clock at three
Damien Batson and there's excellent
patience good ball movement and a
ten-point nipply in any quarter this
season young through the hands of Alex
long has a perfect pass offense first
came home after a West Coast trip is
tough not for these knickerbockers
inside Dodson has it not some brings it
back out turn shoots and scores next to
their first 40 point West quarter of the
season truth I'll coach maybe shoot some
technicals Danny Smith right away
six points couple of assists in three
minutes off the bench
that knocks fires away throws up an air
ball but Mitchell Robinson right there
to put it back up again Nixon now scored
17 straight points dating back in the
end of the first quarter
with the useless stats that comes Smith
and try and force it now before Dennis
Smith it's only a short few minutes good
Leisure's best minutes of the season now
the field day with the useless stats
here comes Smith and try and force it
now the first Dennis Smith it's only a
short few minutes with leisure his best
minutes of the season if I try Acura
Dennis Smith junior doing his thing see
in the floor Bobby Portis delivering
Nixon Rowland to score 21 consecutive
points Robinson swats it at bounds I
think that was going to be a pass the
knick record for most consecutive points
scored is 28 trained young black by
Dennis Smith and RJ Barrett spins into
the trunk for Mara trying to go coast to
coast as Mac jumpers good RJ Barrett now
at 13 that was a nice finish RJ Baron
fumbled the ball a little bit when he
went up to release but he's got so many
nice moves I like when he takes that
little mid-range pull-up jumper Mitchell
puts him with the steal
a dominant first half by the Knicks with
40 seconds remain
[Music]